you
[Music]
okay thank you everyone for coming we're
very happy to have a survey that bill
are visiting us today and tomorrow sorry
that did their PhD with Rachel Ward at
UT Austin and she is now a postdoc with
Afonso Bandera at NYU and she will tell
us about quadratic assignment on data
models okay thank you so much for for
inviting me and okay mm-hm
so I'm gonna talk about quadratic
assignment if you if you haven't seen
the quadratic assignment problem what it
does is you have a and B there n by M
matrices and you can see a PI the set of
n by n permutation matrices and the
quadratic assignment problem asked for
the maximum among all X in the set of M
by M permutation matrices of the trace
of a times X times B times X transpose
that this is a quadratic assignment
problem this this is a very general
problem in theoretical computer science
and it includes many relevant problems
as particular cases one of the problems
is graph matching where you have a graph
a and the graph B and you want to find
the best match in between these two
graphs so if you if you you can write it
as the minimizing of ax minus X B Square
and then when you expand this square you
get ax squared X B Square and then this
term that is exactly this thing because
when when you expand this square this is
constant and this is constant because
it's about this square should be outside
and then then the inner product between
ax and X B is exactly the trace of these
things these transpose what I meant was
just it's not a sub case
yeah it's for symmetric so um then the
graph isomorphism problem is this
deciding whether two graphs are
isomorphic is inciting whether there
exists a matching with objective values
zero is also a particular case of
quadratic assignment and the charleen
salesman problem which asked given a set
of points in you know clean space or
like a metric space you want to find the
best path that covers every point and
minimizes the sum of the distances and
that is the same as asking matching
between this distance square matrix the
pairwise distance matrix and a complete
cycle right so and another problem that
can be posed as a quadratic assignment
is the grammo house or distance of final
metric spaces and I'm gonna talk about
it a little bit in this stock and
something to note is that this problem
is simply hard and even to approximate
it but there a philosophy yes
so the graviton efficient problem is a
particular case it's not equivalent yes
and there is a poly log algorithm - that
is very recent - too salty
try and say don't try alright so yeah
the graphic face I'm sorry and yeah okay
so so being a be hard is a statement
about the worst case instance instance
but np-hard parents can be tractable for
a large set of instances even a dense
set of instances and the real data is
not adversarial so we're gonna focus
yourself worst case complexity in like
some some data malls where we can solve
the problem and what we can do for
different data model and stuff okay so
we're gonna talk about different
techniques that we can use for this for
this problem well
I'm going to talk about semi-definite
programming then they projected power
iteration and some graph neural networks
okay
so the first part I'm going to talk
about semi-definite programming and I'm
the grandma house of distance and this
is a project I did during my PhD and my
collaborate my collaborators are
phonsavanh data with the time with you
andrew bloomer who is it UT austin he's
a professor in algebraic topology and
Rachel Ward who was my PhD advisor for
the GSB yes why it's not the equivalent
to maximum amp to maximizing I mean
you're trying to match the cycle to
embed this cycle into the to the
complete graph with distances and one
night when I do that why is it
well they you can negate one of the
matrices since the function won't change
you can change the max for a mean square
sorry okay I because I Square don't you
I mean negating doesn't matter because
you square is what you're getting for
business um well in the linear in the
Indies in this formulation it doesn't
write you can consider the trace of a BX
[Music]
you can max for me and it's the same is
the same yeah so okay so I'm gonna talk
about the house of this I'm gonna find a
house of distance first so if x and y
are compact sets in a metric space then
you can define the distance from a point
here to this the point in X setting Y as
the as the distance to the point that
minimizes the distance in the other set
and and then you can define the distance
between x and y as you take among all
the distances from points so Y you take
the infimum
sorry this premium and
and you since this definition is not
symmetric between x and y and y and x
then you define house of distance as the
max between the XY or z YX right and so
this is the distance between two sets
there are ml in the same metric space
there's complexes in in a metric space
so if you the grammar house of distance
is defined for two compact metric spaces
that are not necessarily embedded in the
same space and the way it is defined is
if x and y are compact metric spaces
then you consider all isometric
embeddings from X to Z and from Y to Z
to a larger space see and then are you
use you define the distance between x
and y as the house of distance between f
of X the baying of X and the making of Y
and then you take the infimum among all
possible its isometric and weddings and
and this looks hard to compute but then
we'll see how how to compute it and then
the fact is that the grammo House of
distance between two metric spaces is 0
if and only if the spaces are isometric
and this is a is a natural distance
between finite a between metric spaces
it has interesting results and
applications in Romanian geometry and it
has been introduced by Grandma in order
to prove the famous grammar theorem on
growth growth like groups of polynomial
growth that says if you have a finally
generate a group and then you take a
number of generators and then you see
how many elements of the group you can
write as a combination of these
generators and if that grows
polynomially in the number of generators
then it means that your group has a
large part that is abelian like you
community so so in in our case we're
going to think about the gram house or
distance in point clouds and the
motivation to to think of these point
loss is because if you have x and y and
they're compact metric spaces then you
can consider epsilon net which is
subsets where every point in your
manifold is within epsilon of one point
in your epsilon it at least and then if
you take epsilon nets of X and obscenity
of Y and then you take it
epsilon tend to zero then the distance
between x and y is the limit with absent
induces zero of the distance between the
external nets so it's it's a good
approximation to computing in point
clouds to to actually compute it in the
whole metric space and you can use these
two to compare geometric objects like
surfaces but also for example this is a
paper in 2011 in PNAS by the English
division and collaborators where they
they use this they use something similar
to the agreement house of distance like
like using optimal transport they call
it the chroma biased buzzer distance to
compare some teeth and they use it to
produce a taxonomy or like using the
distances between these these teeth and
produced a taxonomy and the species so
they want to classify
so they they use this for scientific
applications but also you wanna you may
want to use these two spaces where the
geometry is less apparent like the image
sequences or electric space is where you
kind of like in this case they use
optimal transport and they use the
geometry of the of the space but maybe
if you don't have a geometric
space where you can use the geometry
like just like some metric spaces like
trees maybe you want to an algorithmic
approach for for this kind of
as well and so if you have mm this two
metric spaces and they're fine it and
how are we going to compute the house or
business so well let's say that X has x1
to xn and y is y1 to yn then we're gonna
say that Delta IJ is 1 if X is related
with white J and 0 otherwise and we're
gonna define this large matrix gamma
with innocence ijkl as the pairwise
distances between X I and XK minus
distance between YJ and white so we we
make this like n by M times n by n
matrix gamma and then the claim this you
can write the quadratic assignment
problem then the following optimization
problem that it's gonna be so you take
from this you take this n matrix and
then you take among all possible
relations between x and y so that every
element in X has a corresponding Y and
every element in Y has correspondence in
X you take the max entrance of these of
of the corresponding like a what X I YJ
I related and if if Y J if these two
points are related and these points are
related then you take the entry of this
matrix does that make sense so this is a
formulation by Facundo memory in 2007 so
every point in X is assigned to some
point yes so so among all possible
relations that every element in Y is
assigned to at least one element in B
next like what was the physical meaning
of it like a lot more matching and it
can be at some point some of much to
anything right sorry so in the in this
like optimal embedding of everything in
the see
some points might not be much to each
other and you even had a picture like
you have like to distort the pictures
some of the points were just like okay
can you explain why this is wrong
so like if you go with it yeah this one
yeah so can you explain like how we get
those so hmm
so every when when you take the distance
between like let's say f of X and G of Y
then for each point you can see there
there's a premium to this - the point to
the other to the other - to the closest
point yes okay okay
does that make sense so it comes from
here basically first so since you need
to take the supremum then every point
needs to be connected so if it's kind of
go back to the previous type even in
this one the equivalent you could just
say that they forget about home just a
house of distance is the smallest
epsilon such that X is within a ball of
radius R epsilon Y in vice versa right
and think about that and it's equivalent
yeah so definitely ways to do these
formulations doing is taking Z to be the
product between x and y okay
okay so it's not set so basically what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna relax these
this and this optimization problem in a
very standard way by lifting this Delta
is an indicator vector and so this is a
quadratic in Delta but it's linear in
the outer product of Delta with itself
so then so we have this and then first
I'm gonna relax the max to a Sun just to
make it differential or like and then we
we consider Delta Z to be the outer
product Delta itself and then Delta IJ
is 0 1 you can relax this also 2 Delta
between the wrong one and so if you if
you see this this Sun is actually the
trace of these Z matrix times the gamma
matrix and so a way to relax this is for
example instead of asking if you if you
have the correct normalization instead
of asking that Delta is Rank 1 you can
relax these to be trace 1 and positive
semi-definite and then the entries of Z
between their own one and this is like
standard way of relaxing this kind of
problem yeah okay well we'll do
something else
so okay so basically you have a now you
used to have a function defined a
discrete set and now we have a convex
set that includes these discrete set and
we are defining another function in this
in this relaxed set and so so basically
yes so we had what you said we had these
max like an infinity norm and we are
accidentally to a one-note the trace and
so this I already said but so now what
we're gonna do is we're going to
consider in fact a familiar relaxation
so we had like infinity like what you
said relaxing to from infinity room to
one norm it's not necessarily really
good but something that you can do is
you can relax these two a P norm and
make P tend to infinity so in fact you
can consider finally relaxations of
Tacoma House of distance that so for
each P you have that the the P relaxed
distance between x and y is the current
the P norm of that relaxation and then
you can make P as much as you want okay
and so you can al so from here that
sorry I'm going back so here so here
this is this is like just the standard
way but then you can add a linear
constraint to make your problem tighter
depending on the on the shape of your
problem and and the constraints that you
have and so if you are certain set of
constraints for example in this case
when the number of points in x and y's
is equal to n that is the same then then
you can actually like decide to consider
more or less constraints to make it
tighter and so basically we have so this
is like a family of this of distances
what you say is like well we don't know
that it's distance yet but we consider
this optimization problem that is a
relaxation of the chroma house of
distance and then for each P the output
the number that is the value of the
optimization problem we're going to call
this to relax VP of X on Y and we see
that in fact this VP for LP is satisfies
the triangle inequality so it's actually
a distance so the value of the
optimization problem is actually some a
semi metric in fact is no
yes I guess I'm Japanese jumping ahead
but this is if you guys like m24 like
yes variable that's something yes okay
yes right yeah so so you can show that
this relaxed distance is also monotonic
as they say p-norm easy clean space and
if x and y are isometric then since okay
it's also a lower bound for the gram oh
how search distance because of the
relaxation and and then if x and y are
isometric then the relaxed distance
between x and y is zero and the geometry
is a solution of testimon if any program
but it's not true they converse like the
it may happen that the distance between
x and y the relaxed systems can be 0 for
non isometric x and y and this is
because the graph isomorphism can be
posed as deciding whether they grow
Mahathir distance between two graphs is
0 and it's known that the graph
isomorphism kind of dissolve with sum of
squares and so there is a there is an
explicit example that you can construct
that sum of squares kind of distinguish
between isomorphic and known as samatha
graphs and there's an explicit
construction using a 3x or and then you
can construct a graph a a graph B and
then if you if you look this sort these
are now tie so I so Norfolk but if you
look at them this immediately program
from it you can extract a soft
assignment that has objective value 0
and it's not so it shows where is the
sum of squares
well the the sum of squares are under
submit you can write some squares to
semi-definite program what they should I
uh know this paper before they showed it
for the canonical yeah yeah they show it
for for that particularly but then if
you say DP or something
the canonical sum of squares for graph
isomorphism it's not equivalent but the
same example like the same construction
oh you're sure you should it also works
that for this case yeah yeah so
something that you can consider is that
okay so now the we have these relax
distance is a semi metric and we wanna
we may want to say what topological
properties it has what is the
convergence and then under this metric
etc and so something that you can see if
that if you have X and all pairwise
distances within X are are different and
you can consider wide that is isometric
to X and then you can see that the semi
definite program has a unique solution
in that case we're all pairwise
distances in the in pneumatic space are
different has a unique solution that is
a geometry and of course the relaxed
distance between x and y is 0 but also
small perturbations of x and y and if
you let's say you fix x and you make a
small perturbation in y because of the
shape of the optimization program you
have the solution isn't like a extreme
point of your convex set if you make a
small perturbation you will obtain the
same solution and so that shows that in
a in a local native neighborhood of x
then the distance is grammo hazard
distance and relaxed distance are
equivalent and therefore you have that
this relaxed distance is a polynomial
time proxy for the grammar hazard
distance that is locally equivalent in a
dense set of points and outside a local
neighborhood of
these relaxed distance this is a local
neighborhood effects these these
distances are not equivalent
so therefore the since the gram the
space of metric the compact metric
spaces with a gram ojas of distance is
geodesic then since these metrics are
equivalent then here is not realistic so
the topology is very very different and
so what Ilya was asking ok computing
this is actually very complicated
because it's a very large semi definite
program so you can do some non convex
efficient algorithm to find a
correspondence or to approximate these
using a DMM for example but of course
you don't have a proof of conversions to
a optima and you can find a local
minimum of the objective function for
example in the correspondence case and
there is a some recent work but by the
group of amid singer where they consider
a very similar semi definite program in
in a in a case for graphs and then they
they reduce the complexity of the semi
definite program by a factor of n by
itself by further relaxing recipe in the
sense of they have this constraint they
have they have this self asking that the
whole matrix is semi definite
they take relevant some matrices and
they ask those relevant some matrices to
be semi definite what is not
didn't you say it's a STP service you
can use like - yes yeah or or maybe you
can use like some boudin Montero where
you use more than drunk one and like you
factor the matrix and say hey transpose
I mean you do some green descent there
for example and not just Rank 1 so you
avoid local minima in that way but but
of course brewing some some results with
respect to those algorithms is hard so I
didn't get where you know when we vary P
where do we get so when you when you're
berry berry P you get closer to the
grandma house artisans like it but so so
there's a way a way you can say it is
here like if you make room yeah well of
course you can you can study how this
will depend on thank you I didn't do it
and also see ya how these depends on P
and Q and make some numeric site I
didn't do it so I don't know we know
something about the gap between the
infinity and the inject yes we know we
know that we know some examples where
for example this is non zero
yeah
okay so is there more questions about
this do you want C maybe towards the end
yeah let's see okay if I have an
animation my website but I don't know
okay so I guess okay so the usual hope
was I just designed this relaxation so
that it's like useful proxy for Graham
of consultants and like applications or
something like this
so how far we have from this being the
case in a way like very able to use it
on some so you you showed some course or
something like this okay you know i it
was i reproduce the results from the
other wishes paper using the demo house
of distance and I actually could
reproduce the results using this
relaxation between the teeth yeah this
like edge cells then I should use this
like not obvious um three reasonably
well well so there's two things right if
you want to compute a number as the
distance or if you want to find the
limiting right so if you want to find it
if you find matching of course you can
get a number as the distance but the you
don't have these these topological
properties that we so if you want to do
an experiment where you only care about
the number then you may want to find
like for example you say a meaty singer
called for for running this company this
SVP and obtaining this number so what i
did was i yeah i reproduce it with the
SCP and also it is so what's the largest
set of points that
very secret I'm not sure but I think I I
didn't my computer with 50 points which
is not a lot yeah we use people's one
versus another or yeah because why
okay so
so now I'm gonna talk about different
flavor of algorithm that I will apply to
this product to a very similar problem
that is a projected power iteration in
the case that I'm thinking of now is a
graph matching so there's this eigen
align algorithm that given a and B two
graphs you construct gamma matrix very
similar to the one that we had before
that gamma IJ prime a is gonna be one so
you have these two graphs and IR is an
edge in the first graph and J prime s
prime is a well sorry yeah in the second
graph and you put a 1 if you are in this
case and you put a 0 if you are in a
different case right so basically if you
have an edge here and an edge here you
put a 1 and then 0 otherwise
and the algorithm just simple thing you
take the top I can factor of gamma and
you round it to a permutation so yes
that's a very good question so something
that you can do is you you can solve a
linear program like you know minimize
you maximize it with a good cost
polytope so so you you given this vector
you write it as some matrix is a square
matrix and then you take the maximum of
that times X such that X is by
stochastic and then you know that the
solution of that linear program is going
to be integer because all the vertices
are so so what you do is then you have
this a top I can vector you write it as
a matrix and then you consider the max
of that vector
in a product with X such that X is by
stochastic matrix place but I'm still
crashing all right
no because so this this I okay so now
this algorithm will work in a very very
few instances for example if there if
there is if gamma has the it's not the
top eigenvector it's not simple like
there's more like more than one I came
back to with the same eigenvalue then
it's not gonna work and and just and if
you if you have a lot of noise then it's
also no it's not gonna work but that's
like a baseline so basically what we
want to do is we want to modify this
this algorithm to see if we can make it
work in a more general case so this this
comes from it from the idea that for
example when you want to do clustering
you can't consider spectral clustering
you take let's say that you wanna find
two clusters you take a top eigenvector
of distance matrix or a laplacian and
then and then you see this this this top
eigenvector works in a very good case
where the clusters are separated but
sometimes you can actually modify what
lesson you take the top again vector and
and then you get the classroom works
better in that case and this is this is
a work that is very precise and worked
by Emanuel Ax and Remington airy and
they study algorithms of this form
likewise the best spectrum Ethel for
this class in Imperium so this is
basically what we want to do here like
look for a good spectral method in in
this quadratic assignment problem so
we're going to consider projected power
iteration where
one can think of this question so what's
the problem we're solving we're okay oh
wait we're gonna find them matching a
and B two graphs and we want to find
matching so much history so it's like we
want permutation oh sorry what yes so
that was the same as before
right there say crap eyes along be
something yes I see so we did not get
one for every age that will march and
otherwise it's zero you know three cases
so so number of number of common areas
so you went out like maximize the trace
of a X BX transpose and X ah okay so
we're solving we are solving engineering
problem but for the case where a and B
are 0 what medicine yeah I'm there yeah
and they symmetric symmetric yeah so
we're gonna go see it projected power
iteration and the idea is that when you
take the top I connector you can you can
do it using up a power method you start
with a vector and then you multiply the
matrix times a vector and we multiply
that times the matrix again and again
until convergence and these they project
the power iteration what it does is it
may it as a threshold in step after each
iteration of the power method right so
instead of multiply matrix times matrix
times vector u multiplied you you do
matrix inspector and then you threshold
that and then you multiply it by matrix
again and then you threshold that so you
you do address holding after each step
so the trash holding can be a rounding
to the set there
like a complete projection to your set
or you choose a closed point in your set
or or just just some trash holding or
some softening but not necessarily going
to the set of permutations and something
that you can also do is okay so here you
know that okay the multiplication of
gamma times V and if you look at the
position T then you get this
multiplication of the matrix times the
vector is going to be L is the sound for
all the entries so there is a way you
can something that you may want to do is
to avoid the backtracking terms meaning
that you can think of what the position
what BL has in this in this L position
is going to affect what gamma P has in
the position T and you don't you want to
avoid backtracking in terms meaning that
you don't want that what L had in the
previous step affecting what L has in
the future step like it's just like some
regularization that you can do and this
this regularization is is it's used for
this where they call approximate message
passing algorithms and in fact if you if
you have if you want to remove this this
thing you can write it out as like as
then
like regular multiplication of the
matrix plus some correction term that
comes from removing the backtracking
terms and this is called the on seller
term in approximate message-passing
algorithms that you can compute
explicitly and basically what this is
this is an ongoing project and basically
Cali what we do is just realize that
this this projected power iteration
actually can't recover the alignment
between the grass in some specific
setting so here we consider this
experiment where a is an erdos-renyi
graph or you take two nodes in your
graph and you say with probability here
one half independently there is an l2 or
not and B is a plus some noise where
with some probability you change a 0 to
a 1 and a 1 to 0 and we see that the
eigen line algorithm will recover
perfectly very matching between this and
a me if 9os is 0 and if it's not 0 then
you can see that this this gray is like
the proportion of the recovered matching
matching and here we do the same with
the projected power iteration so
basically what we're doing is some
regularized spectral method where we are
this number tracking term and we
observed that it actually performs
better than the simple
just one term was missing from the sound
think so yes
so what is it so the only difference is
that L is not equal to capital T yes so
why do you think about the dust effect
track you mean there's no future here
you mentioned like you're maybe not
making the thing influencing the future
but we're only talking about two
consecutive
iterations right so you can like one one
step you don't go back once one step
like you can think of you have the
sequence B one B etc and then what you
what you imagine is that they be in the
entry I effects what they be in the
entry for the next V in the entry J will
be and what you don't want is to eat
effect to itself like yes it's like
random words
yes but even if you have that
performance I mean in other words we can
still have even lazier in the works
right I mean some loose you shouldn't
affect too much of course it depends so
like is it really very crucial here to
remove this well numerically we observed
that he improves the performance but so
basically this yes yes good approach
like this work well in the sparse ating
like if you have a sparse random graph
versus sparse random graph with noise I
don't know if you have way to social
networks and you hope to like might them
and like figure out is the same set of
people I need others and just thinking
about applications of that could be so
we showed plots for the advanced case
right yes this is yeah this is a dense
case yeah so basically so we want we we
consider this this setting because
something that you need is that the
graph doesn't have symmetries in order
for the
approach to work because if the graphs
that have symmetries then you you cannot
hope to recover anything so with we high
probability if you if you have a graph
with this correctly we don't you don't
need that P so high but at those rainy
graphs so I think that if they if the
graph doesn't have symmetries then an
approach like these will work when
there's no noise and then it's possible
that this approach will do better but I
here in these two graphs
you didn't even introduce a permutation
of their nose you just yeah but this
kind of data what could happen algorithm
the cheeks but your honor so so I would
want so you don't apply like a random
permutation to the nodes yes but it
doesn't matter I mean you'll recover
like you record the permutation like if
you had a permutation and and you don't
have noise then you will record
different the permutation so even
without doing you have to graph
isomorphism probably so yeah yes that I
so but this is the case what if a graph
isomorphism problem is easy yeah yeah so
we are saying that if B would be a plus
noise and then round up the rotation and
still get the same cloth just because of
yeah okay
so in order to understand these this
algorithm and this is an ongoing project
that i'm working with Afonso and ADA who
is to understand what what these
approximate message-passing
will why is it threshold for recovery
for this approximate message passing
algorithm in this context this is known
for for this elastic block model but
this different harder problem and see if
we can use the techniques that they use
for them for for predicting the
threshold for recovery in the stochastic
block model for this particular problem
and how and how does this compare to the
statistical threshold like where the
praline is statistically possible but
the algorithm doesn't doesn't work and
something else that I wanted to talk
about and I'll do it fast is another
approach that is see if you can use
graph neural networks to to learn the
solutions of learnings of this form so
this is something that I work with the
phone saw Alex and John that I anyway
you and John is an expert in in neural
networks so and so basically some
heuristic aliy what one can say is that
the neural network I hit the
architecture resembles this projected
power iteration in a very high-level way
that is they you have a linear
application and then you have a
nonlinear step in your application
nonlinear step etc and then in the in
the neural network like you you give
you're given some some data that you
want to add like data they use for
learning and then you use stochastic
gradient sent to too much X like entries
X and
outputs white and then you want to
minimize the loss function that here you
consider them their nonlinear steps
the Nanyan functions are fixed and the
linear functions something that you
learn and the success of these
algorithms depends that on the landscape
of this loss function to be nice and to
allow cyka security in descent to
converge to a local minima in some way
and that the learn function achieves the
small journey station error so so here
when we are going to consider is a is
the graph and M is a set of operators of
the graph the identity the degree and
then powers of the adjacency matrix of
the graph and then we are gonna find is
we're gonna say okay the step t plus 1
of a back-door like the application t
plus 1 of this vector is going to be
what you learn is a way of combining the
operators of the graph and multiply them
by you move so you apply these operators
in this V and then this theta is the
parameters that you learn so basically
what you're learning is the way you
combine these operators of photograph
like for example you can think of a
spectral method that is the cut
regularized spectral method so you have
alpha times identity plus beta times the
degree x plus gamma times the laplacian
and that is something that you can use
for example for clustering and here what
you're learning is how you combine this
degree with what this alpha beta and
gamma will be but here in this set of
neural networks the set of parameters is
much larger and the set of operators
that you consider can be much larger and
so these are the the trainable
parameters and what you do is I
subscription jiho's
i Peter D sub M comma I work what is the
I index and where this we call so L is
okay so you can this vector is not gonna
be just one vector it's gonna be a
matrix that it's gonna be like an
embedding of your graph so L is
they number of columns so I guess when
these are when the DTS are like one
day's internetwork so this is what one
general a very personal
so the linear the linear part is gonna
be this okay so we've served you've said
like calligraphic camp has just identity
what would it be
that's certainly not something you
regret
Boise then you have just one sways to
layer and with smoking okay so it's not
interesting so what's the point of
having L I I understand I think the
equation that okay okay so um you you
just learn an embedding of your graph Oh
to 2 T 2 DT that's like right so so
precisely if yourself has just identity
would be usual neural network right no I
think so you have just one wait you just
it's just a no Caleb you have geeky
waits for where TT by little bit em and
misses having somebody over and oh okay
okay so it's like L independent columns
yeah I said
so basically what you do is you you
learn embeddings for photographs and
then you you want to minimize the the
loss of how the outer product of this
embedding the milling of a and the
baying of feet being close to identity
different coordinates interacting there
any production in sales you can think of
it instead of taking the top eigenvector
you can take like okay top eigenvectors
for your grass so team T is the the
layer the delay of the arranges but V T
which is in there is that matrix the
columns so so these are not independent
there is no subscript okay so it's kind
of like you're learning how each of the
columns of B T would be as a combination
of the of operators of this form so so
if you if you only have a l equals one
then you only will have one kind of like
eigenvector for for your for your pain
that's my question again so if click
graphic and just have identity and now
that we understood the dry interactions
that would be just like usual your own
networks yes yeah okay so so here what
you're doing is you're learning a way to
combine the operators for the graph
right the open
you care about the graph so in
particular this is this architecture is
invariant to permutations so if I have a
permutation in a like if I permute two
rows of a rows and columns of a then
what happens is that you obtain the same
permutation in B so it's inviting two
permutations in that sense right so in
particular you can just think that you
want to learn the identity and if you
have a permutation then you will learn
the permutation that you want so so if
you learn an embedding for a and then an
embedding for B and if you if you know
that you want to match a with B then the
loss function that you want to use is
the KL divergence of how far away is
this outer product of them being with a
and B with a identity and you can train
this a with a or the training graph and
be a plus noise and see how it performs
and the way it performs is okay so here
I have in red the so here is the noise
level and in the y-axis that recovery
rate and we have that semi definite
program is the right one and then the
graph neural network is the green one
and the black one is the projected pal
iteration for this particular model
where where the matching is not hard
right and so
another thing that we want to do is to
see the trailing Statesman problem with
this graph neural networks so the we can
do it in two ways one way is to use the
input of the graph and input as the
graph and the ground truth of the
training segment cycle to train the
model like okay given the graph this is
the Traveling Salesman problem let's say
that you find it with an every second
and you want to see if your graph neural
network coloring that and the other and
on the other possible way to do it is
you consider the minimizing of the cost
of the practice cycle as the loss
function so which one do you think will
be better like you let's say that you
have an Oracle that gives you the
solution from the training salesman
problem and then you have graph planted
solution and then you want to match that
or the other one is you just take the
the length of the path as the classic
cost distribution on brows yes of course
you need to have that distribution
graphs in order to train your or or
maybe you have data a lot of data so in
fact what what we do so it seems like
the second one would be more natural but
we did the first one because these the
cost of the practice I cycle it's not
differentiable with respect to the to
the parameter being the parameters
- so the second approach you are solving
a harder problem technique would not
like you because you're trying to be
able to predict the cost of any
arbitrary part of the graph that you're
trying to get a predictor and then what
you want to do is a post process through
this predictor you want to now search
through all possible paths and find the
shortest path okay so I all I need to
know is something that predicts the
shortest path and I don't need to have a
predictor that can predict the cost of
any possible cycle yeah okay roundabout
way of getting people yeah so so
basically with with that we we train it
with this Oracle solution and then we
got we got that it works in some sense
it's not it's not optimal but and also
they predicted cycles do not look
exactly like like the target circle
cycles but they look close which is
interesting and I don't know how to
explain it but yeah and so basically no
I won't be that so the question is can
you learn it yes but at least in the way
we have it it's not it's cool yes random
so it's like anything works well on
those so yeah these graphs of 2 percent
and 1 percent would slow yeah it's
probably from maybe a line neural net
for the problem would not have worked
but and this crap need a definition of
you know yeah yeah
which in the worst case gives three hops
but on these instances oh okay so so
things that I'm working on anyway you
with the experts that we have there is -
ok to understand the approximate message
passing from the bug tracking spectral
methods like in the in the case the
second part of the problem and see this
is statistical noise signal plus noise
and see the threshold for recovery and
try to understand this graph neural
networks why they can learn what kind of
things they can learn how would they
perform it cetera and they local minima
this kind of problems on and just that
this is this set is gonna be the rest of
the day and tomorrow I had questions
would you like to show us yes I want my
counsel it's not like